hey this is Mel and this lecture is on
greenhouse gases and the greenhouse
effect before we get into the greenhouse
stuff we're going to talk a little bit
about light and one of the ideas in
light is that light travels in waves
so there's several things in physics
that travel as ways so for example we
have sound waves right earthquake waves
so energy can propagate as waves
sometimes and light is one of those
things so if you think about what a wave
would look like so I'm just going to
draw some waves here so now when we get
into waves in physics there's some
terminology that we use a lot and one of
them is something called wavelength so
if I had a bunch of waves here and I
measure the distance between two
consecutive parts on a wave we call that
the wavelength so for example from
trough to trough or crest to crest
that's the literally the length of the
wave so light is made of waves that are
so small that you can't see them how
small are they so you can imagine if you
took a meter stick and you divide it
into million pieces and then you take
one of those pieces and you divide it
into about 10 to 50 pieces and take one
of those pieces that's about the length
of a wavelength of light okay so these
are sub microscopic waves right so we
think of them and we draw them like this
but we can't actually see the waves
themselves there's everything that's way
too microscopic okay
these waves the way our eyes and brains
are set up is what we perceive as color
are actually different wavelengths of
light so when I see red light that's a
certain wavelength when I
say blue light that's a different
wavelength the waves are physically
different sizes and our eyes and brains
interpret that as a color okay so what
I'm gonna do is we're gonna draw if we
could look at all of the waves from the
Sun okay so I'm gonna make a graph here
on the x-axis are the waves shorter
waves are down here longer waves over
here and on the y-axis is intensity so
we're gonna look at all the light coming
from the Sun they were gonna make a
graph now I did so it would kind of look
like this so it's not symmetrical
there's a peak and then there's this
really long tail that actually goes on
forever off the page and if I drew it
correctly it would never come down to
zero but I kind of screwed up there a
little bit okay so let's explain kind of
what this means
on this end these are the waves coming
from the Sun that are really short so
I'm gonna draw a little line kind of
right here because it turns out those
waves are too short for our eyes to see
then we start to get into waves that our
eyes can see and the shortest ones that
we can see our eyes interpret that as
violet so I'm just gonna shade this
cover violet purple cover and then
eventually as these waves get longer and
longer we interpret them to be more of a
blue color so I'm gonna put some blue in
here and I'm not gonna draw every color
that we can see I'm just kind of
generalizing here okay so then as the
waves get longer they turn more and more
of a green color so I'm gonna draw
some green Hey and then as they get
longer still we start to get into the
yellow and then we get into some orange
which then turns more and more towards a
red color okay so something like this so
I'm gonna put another little dashed line
right there
so roughly and this is really rough but
the idea is that over here we've got
waves that are too short to see then we
get into violet then in the blues greens
and then as the waves get longer and
longer we eventually see that as red and
eventually they are too long to see okay
now the ones that are too long to see we
call those infra red sometimes we
abbreviate this as IR and the waves that
are too short to see we call those ultra
violet or UV so UV is this entire region
in here
infrared is this entire region that goes
off the page
let's talk about UV first so we've
talked about UV in the past we talked
about the ozone layer and how the ozone
layer blocks most but not quite all of
the UV from hitting the surface right so
UV
light comes in hits an ozone own so
breaks apart eventually gets back
together that releases heat to the
stratosphere okay so this little segment
right here
of UV is the UV that gets through it's
the UV that gets all the way to the
surface and the UV out here this is the
UV that's blocked by the ozone layer
okay so this whole the the shorter these
shorter waves it turns out have more
energy and they're more dangerous to us
so for us
things like x-rays and gamma rays those
are even shorter than this unfortunately
we have very few of those coming into
the atmosphere from the Sun but those
are very dangerous and then the longer
the wavelength is it turns out the safer
it is for for us for our bodies okay so
you don't want to get whacked with UV
radiation it's okay to get whacked with
visible radiation which is what we call
this part in here this is the part that
we can see then we get up here to these
longer wavelengths and now we're back to
waves that we can no longer see now the
ones that are pretty close to red in
here we call this near-infrared and the
ones that are way out here on this tail
we call these far infrared so everything
in the tail is infrared
NIR is this these guys far and it goes
goes on and on and on on this page goes
on forever
okay also when you get far out on this
tail and it's kind of off the page but
I'm going to draw it here anyway you get
to some radiation that is it we can't
see it but we have another sense for it
you would call this heat so if you were
up to let's say you walk up to a wall
and the wall is hot you have a sense
that it's hot without actually having to
touch it right like you can you can you
since it on your face like you feel
something and out here we call this
sensible heat not sensible because it
has good sense but sensible and that
it's not if you remember back some
lectures we talked about latent heat
latent heat is heat that is hidden
sensible heat is not hidden you can
touch it and feel it so what we perceive
as and what we talk about is sensible
heat that touched something warm and
feels warm that is actually I'm feeling
these waves way out here our eyes can't
see them now it's worth pointing out
that some animals can see other waves
that we cannot write so we can't see
near-infrared right here but snakes for
example pit vipers they have this little
pit on their head and it's a sensor and
they can see things that are warm and
they're kind of seeing they don't really
see this out here but they kind of see
the near-infrared part of that a lot of
insects can see UV out here and so I
helps them see different flowers so our
our world is the visible you know the
vit what we call the visible light world
these are the ways that we see but we're
surrounded with these other waves that
we cannot so with that I'm going to then
move to talk about how this what this
has anything they do with greenhouse
effect what we do when we talked about
the greenhouse effect is we take all of
these waves and we group them into two
categories we basically say that
everything from about here onward is
called shortwave radiation okay and so
sometimes that means all the visible and
UV sometimes people also include the
near-infrared but it's the majority this
hump that's the shortwave radiation and
everything to the right of this
is long-wave radiation so that is this
long tail that again it's it's much it's
much longer than I'm showing here goes
off the page so all the waves to the
right of this we call long wave
radiation all the ways to the left of
this we call short wave radiation okay
so we're gonna talk about short wave
radiation long wave radiation and just
keep in mind when you hear short wave
it's the stuff you see with the UV when
you see long wave radiation it's these
really long waves that you can't see but
you might be able to feel as sensible
heat so one of the things that happens
on earth is that shortwave radiation
comes in from the Sun and the earth
absorbs that and turns it into long wave
radiation okay so the way I would draw
that is so here's the surface there's
the Sun and mostly what comes in from
the Sun is shortwave radiation that's
the big hump of radiation we just drew
and it comes down and it goes through
space unaffected goes through the
atmosphere mostly unaffected hits the
ground and the ground absorbs this and
then the ground turns it into a long
wave radiation and so coming off of the
ground beaming back into space is long
wave radiation so this is the long wave
this is the short way
okay so remember that from the previous
diagram shortwave that's all mostly the
visible plus a little bit on each side
what's coming back what's coming off the
earth is a stuff way out here including
the heat that you can feel so you can
kind of think of the earth is converting
one type of radiation to the other we
see visible light weak comes in hits the
ground turns into heat that you can feel
so here's an illustration sun's out turn
you back to the Sun you back gets warm
why it's not heat coming from the Sun
it's shortwave radiation coming from the
Sun your heat your back absorbs that
turns it into long wave and then you can
sense it
so objects that are in the sunlight
take that shortwave radiation convert it
to a long wave radiation now in the
earth this long wave radiation is
beaming back out into space okay so if
you have any object floating out in
space earth the moon whatever it absorbs
the shortwave beams long wave back so
you if you're floating around out in
space and you had a thermometer you
could point it at the earth you would
measure this coming off of it so the
earth is like beaming this long wave
radiation out in space kind of like how
the Sun beams shortwave radiation out
into space okay so this is what's going
on with the earth so with that we're
going to investigate what greenhouse
what the greenhouse gas what a
greenhouse gas is and what the
greenhouse effect is and all that so
this is another one of the Phet
simulations it's called the greenhouse
effect and what we have here is a box
and I can put a different kind of
molecule on the box so nitrogen oxygen
water co2 whatever and I've got a
flashlight that can shoot either
shortwave radiation or long-wave
radiation now what they're calling it
here is they're calling it infrared so
that's a long wave radiation and I can
turn on the slider and it's
start shooting well we call photons a
little packets of light that are either
so what they're calling infrared we just
call it a long way so these are a long
way this is little packets a long wave
radiation or I can switch it to the
visible light which is the shortwave
radiation okay
and it shows whether what it's showing
here is that the photons are just
passing right through my oxygen molecule
and nothing's happening and I can switch
this to nitrogen and again no matter
what I do the different types of light
just go right through so so far nothing
really interesting is happening what's
our atmosphere made out of roughly
eighty percent nitrogen twenty percent
oxygen and so when I put these molecules
in there nothing happens right okay so
let's say I change this though and I'm
gonna put in a water molecule okay so I
got water molecules and so just remind
you there's the the two oxygen sorry the
two hydrogen's on one side and it kind
of has that Mickey Mouse head shape we
talked about in the past so if I change
this to shoot long wave radiation at it
I notice that finally something's
different starts happening and once in a
while the water molecule absorbs one of
those photons of long wave radiation it
gets excited it wiggles and then it
shoots it off in some random direction
okay so as I sit here and watch this you
know if I was standing behind this
flashlight doing this once in a while
one of those red photons of long wave
radiation would come back towards me now
we just said that long wave radiation
includes sensible heat which you can
feel alright so if you can imagine me
shooting these little photons of long
wave radiation at this water molecule
and occasionally one of them comes back
towards me like that one right there
then my experience as the guy behind the
flashlight is I feel the warmth of that
little photons coming back okay so I'm
gonna make a bunch of them
let's build a nap
fear I'm gonna put a bunch of waters out
here and I'm gonna turn on my flashlight
America and I start spraying this box of
water molecules with photons of long
wave radiation and as I stand back here
I'll notice that occasionally some of
them come back towards me okay this is
what we call the greenhouse effect and
water is a greenhouse gas because it
does this not all gases do this so I
just Illustrated this but if I had a
bunch of let me take my waters back come
on
and I'm going to increase my got a bunch
of oxygens and I got a bunch of
nitrogen's and now I will shoot those
guys and that the the long wave
radiation just passes right through and
you sees molecules just don't care
nothing's happening so none of those
photons are getting reflected back
towards me at any point on the other
hand if I went to let's get rid of my
nitrogen let's get rid of my oxygen come
on and I could put in some co2 so co2 is
another one of these molecules that acts
as a greenhouse gas you can see they get
excited occasionally and they shoot off
a photon in some random direction and
that random direction might be back
towards where I am methane nothing isn't
as a CH floor has carbon with four
hydrogen's so I go back here and make a
atmosphere with methane and
so as I shoot the methane with the
long-wave radiation you can see it also
gets partly absorbed and reflects back
towards me
it's also worth pointing out that if I
put the flashlight on visible so
shortwave radiation and I fill up the
atmosphere with nitrogen and oxygen that
the shortwave radiation goes through the
atmosphere completely unaffected and if
I put in greenhouse gases so methane co2
water that nothing is affected here in
other words the shortwave radiation
pretty much just goes right through the
atmosphere so it's coming from the Sun
goes to the atmosphere does not interact
with hardly any gases it's the long-wave
radiation that is interacting with the
greenhouse gases
okay so oxygen nitrogen no interaction
whatsoever with anything the greenhouse
gases and so far we've seen co2 water
and methane do interact with a long wave
radiation
okay so let's return back to this
diagram that we just drew and what we
have drawn here is a scenario on a
planet that has no greenhouse gases so
let's just say our atmosphere was oxygen
nitrogen we have no greenhouse gases or
maybe no atmosphere at all shortwave
radiation comes in hits the ground goes
back out into space as long wave
radiation if the earth had no greenhouse
gases whatsoever just oxygen nitrogen
then our average temperature
the entire planet is somewhere around
four degrees Fahrenheit okay
so this takes into this is the whole
earth now so it's the poles is the
equator it's the summers it's the
winters the days of the night it's all
thrown together you get a number about
four degrees Fahrenheit so pretty close
to zero Fahrenheit what's what would the
earth be like if the average temperature
is about zero that means you're looking
at an earth that is essentially entirely
frozen the oceans would probably be
frozen completely over right so that's
what it would be like if we had no
greenhouse gases okay so now let's let's
take this scenario and let's add one
thing what if we had a planet that had
clouds okay so we're just gonna do that
first so redraw okay so in this scenario
we have clouds and so I'm gonna draw
these as some physical objects in the
sky
okay and what happens
well shortwave radiation still comes
down from the Sun as before which I'm
drawing is blue and clouds will reflect
some of that shortwave radiation back
out into space okay so that's a
possibility and one of the things that
we'll do is that will help cool it down
during the day right so cloudy day
usually not as hot it's because we're we
are reflecting some of that shortwave
radiation back out into space but the
the short way some of it still gets to
the ground and still turns into long
wave and long wave then heads out into
space just like before but the
difference now is that we have some
clouds so as so so some of it
we'll make it all about the space right
that will mix it up of space but maybe
this one hits this cloud and some of it
goes through but some of it reflects
back this one hits the cloud some of it
goes through some of it reflects back
okay so if you are an observer on the
ground down here so we're sitting we're
saying this is the same planet as before
so the planet before had no greenhouse
gases it was zero degrees the person on
that previous planet could feel the
warmth coming up from the surface this
person also feels the warmth coming up
from the surface but but now there's a
little portion of it that's coming down
from above so in other words this little
reflection may come down and hit you and
you now feel like there's a little bit
of warmth coming up from those clouds so
the presence of clouds and so we've kind
of skipped greenhouse gases here for a
little bit but the presence of clouds
means that you will have cooler days but
you'll have warmer nights
okay so generally speaking if it's
clutch you know especially in the winter
if it's cloudy at night it's gonna be
much warmer at night than it is if it's
clearer at night because a lot of this
long wave radiation that's coming up is
reflecting off of these clouds and
coming back towards you and so just to
be clear make sure what I'm doing here
all my red ones those are all long long
wave radiation going out towards this
toward space so so so the big picture
here is everything is the same as before
except these clouds are going to cause
some reflections some reflections of
shortwave back out into space
makes things cooler some reflection of
long wave radiation coming back down
makes things warmer so the big picture
is a cloudy planet going to be warmer at
night probably cooler during the day
okay so now here's our third scenario
now we have an atmosphere that has some
greenhouse gases and I've drawn some
greenhouse gases here I've not drawn in
oxygen in nitrogen because as we've just
kind of demonstrated they have nothing
to do with either a long wave or
shortwave radiation so I'm not drawing
them I just threw in some some
greenhouse gases we've got some methane
we've got some water we got some co2
okay so what happens in this scenario
shortwave radiation still comes in from
the Sun so here's my shortwave coming in
and long-wave radiation
heads out to space from the from the
surface and as it goes out you know some
of it comes out and goes all the way
until it you know it goes all the way
out into space and sometimes it will
interact with one of these greenhouse
gases so back to the animation where the
greenhouse gas got excited and wiggled
and it shot that photon in a random
direction well that's what's happening
here
this outgoing there's my long wave
coming out is going to interact with
this co2 co2 gets excited Wiggles shoots
out a photon in some random direction
okay and this is happening all
throughout here where some of these
interactions are sending the long-wave
radiation in various random directions
I'm just going to draw a few of them
because it takes forever
so well I'm trying to draw here is that
there's all these interactions occurring
with greenhouse gases now eventually
this long wave radiation will make it
out to space right you know it'll bounce
back and forth between one molecule and
what have you eventually it'll get out
but before it gets out the person on the
ground down here is experiencing these
photons a long wave radiation coming
back down out of the sky now before we
say they're coming down reflecting off a
cloud well in this case we have no
clouds but they're still coming back
down they're reflecting off of these
invisible gases these greenhouse gases
so if this one for example comes down to
the ground and hits this person this
person feels warmer well eventually if
we just think about where that
ultimately goes it'll eventually head
back out into space and it may reflect
back and forth several times but it'll
eventually get out it'll eventually go
out into into space but you can think of
this as like we're recycling some of
these long these parties photons of long
wave radiation it was all headed to
space it got intercepted on the way
there
got rerouted back down towards the
surface some of it and then as it hits
the surface that it's back headed back
out to space for a second or third or
fourth or fifth time so this is what we
mean by greenhouse effect the greenhouse
effect means we have these molecules
that has has this property of being able
to absorb
Longway radiation redirect it in a
random direction that random direction
could be back down towards the surface
in which case it makes the surface
warmer than initially was going to be
that's the greenhouse effect and because
of the greenhouse effect the worldwide
average temperature
is about 54 degrees okay
and that's lucky for us because that's
above freezing so we could not survive
without the greenhouse effect
so prior we said that without the
greenhouse effect the entire earth is
below freezing okay we have to have the
rehouse effect to survive on this planet
it just turns out that in the last 100
ish years or so we as humans have been
adding too much of a good thing to the
planet and into the atmosphere and we
are increasing this greenhouse effect so
as we get into climate change what what
I want you to keep clear is you got to
have the greenhouse effect you got to
have it otherwise we die right but we've
got it a little too much of it now and
so things are warming up because we are
reflecting more of those long wave
photons back towards the surface that
are that are supposed to be here okay
we're going to return to that Phet
animation and we were looking at this
tab called photon absorption and now
we're going to go over to greenhouse
effect and what they're trying to show
they're trying to animate basically what
we just drew they're using yellow to
represent shortwave radiation from the
Sun so these little yellow photons
that's the visible light plus the UV
maybe some near-infrared coming down and
this the red represents the long wave
radiation going back out into space okay
so this is what we drew as arrows I used
the color blue they're using the color
yellow
but there's photons coming down there's
photons going out no greenhouse gases
and it shows that the worldwide
temperature is about in this case looks
like it's about minus 2 pretty close to
zero zero degrees Fahrenheit right so
the world is frozen now what I can do
with this is I can put in greenhouse
gases and watch how things change so
right now this entire time I've had this
says greenhouse gas concentration have
had it all
and I'm gonna turn it up to somewhere in
the middle here and what I want you to
do is notice how the red ones change
their behavior you'll notice if you
watch one for a while it'll suddenly
change direction that's where it's
interacting with a greenhouse gas
molecule and kind of like I drew with
arrows reflecting these little photons
of long-wave radiation are headed out to
space but before they get there they
often get intercepted redirected and a
lot of them come back down towards the
surface so what that means is the
surface is getting warm and you can see
the temperature has been rising here
okay so this is the greenhouse effect
and they're not showing you the
molecules I drew those in on our last
paper but it's showing it's animating
the effect that the greenhouse effect
produces I could also just turn it all
the way up so I'm going to crank it all
that we have greenhouse gas
concentrations all the way Taurus has
lots and you'll see a lot more
interactions with the red maliki the red
photons you see a lot of them bouncing
around meaning that they're interacting
with greenhouse gas molecules coming
back towards the surface and we see that
that surface temperature is now
increasing looks like it's getting up to
over 70 degrees now remember what this
means this is not 70 degrees I mean that
doesn't sound bad at all
that's a worldwide global average so
it's also including the poles and the
days and nights and the winners and
everything right so worldwide the entire
temperature is increasing if I increase
the greenhouse gas concentrations so
we're going to talk about some of these
different greenhouse gases but before we
do that we're going to talk a little bit
about some of the gases we've talked
about so far in class and so early on in
the semester we talked about how the
atmosphere is mostly oxygen and nitrogen
a little bit of argon a little bit co2 a
little bit of water vapor and then up in
the stratosphere a little bit of ozone
right so these are all naturally
occurring
and we did a section on air pollution we
talked about gases some of these are
human created some of these are
naturally occurring but humans add to
that so things like carbon monoxide so2
NOx and all those things so that was
part of our air pollution unit okay so
now we have a third category gases that
we're calling greenhouse gases okay and
all of the greenhouse gases we can
subdivide them into two categories one
is naturally-occurring greenhouse gases
that we as humans are adding to and then
there's a second category of greenhouse
gases that we as humans have just
created there are synthetic molecules
okay
so before we get to further in on this
we're going to really be focusing on
this group right here co2 ch4 and n2 oh
and we're not going to really talk about
water vapor even though water vapor is
the most abundant greenhouse gas in the
atmosphere so why would we not talk
about this well if you go back to when
we talked about humidity we said that
the amount of water vapor in the
atmosphere is controlled strongly by
temperature so warm air has a higher
possible maximum mixing ratio right and
if they cool the air down remember we
hit the dew point we condense water out
so what water vapor cannot stay in the
atmosphere if the atmosphere is too cold
right so if we all as humans got
together and started adding water vapor
to the atmosphere on purpose let's say
it won't stay in the atmosphere more
than maybe a few days before it drifts
off into someplace cold condenses out
and it gets removed from the atmosphere
the greenhouse gases that we're
interested in are the ones that are not
being removed in a short time okay so
that's why we're not really talking
about water vapor even though water
vapor is a pretty significant greenhouse
gas okay so so it turns out the
strengths of greenhouse gases are not
all the same and if you think back to
the animation we're shooting molecules
with the little gun
you know occasionally molecule got
excited and absorbed that photon of
radiation and then re-emitted it okay
well some molecules absorb radiation
much easier than others they are much
more efficient at being greenhouse gases
and so we have this system called global
warming potential or GWP and what we say
is that greenhouse gasses so on the Left
these are all greenhouse gases and by
the way if you're one of my students
what I'm showing you here are part of
what we used to have handouts and my
face-to-face class so this is on learn
so you can find this document in some of
the future slides too so what we say is
that co2 has a GWP of one okay we just
aren't this arbitrary so methane ch4 has
a GWP of 25 so what that means is ch4
per molecule is 25 times as powerful of
a greenhouse gas as co2 so if I had one
molecule of ch4 it's worth twenty-five
molecules of co2 or if I take nitrous
oxide n2o it has a global warming
potential 298 so one molecule of nitrous
oxide is worth 298 molecules of co2 so
greenhouse gases all have very different
strengths and what we want to do here is
we want to be able to compare different
sources to see which emissions are
actually affecting the greenhouse effect
more and so if I go back a slide these
were the naturally occurring ones and we
as humans add them that's these three
and then all these are synthetic we as
humans make them they don't occur in
nature notice though how strong some of
these are this one has a GWP 14800 so
one single molecule of HFC 23 is worth
about 15,000 co2 molecules also notice
that they are up in the atmosphere
sometimes for a very long time and we
look at this see CF 4 has an atmospheric
lifetime of 50,000 years meaning that
it gets in the atmosphere there's no
natural processes that break this down
it's gonna be up there a very very long
time okay so what we want to do is let's
imagine a scenario we we've got three
different greenhouse gas emitters I'd
say three different factories but
they're not all emitting the same gas
you've got one emitting co2 you get one
emitting methane you get one mini
nitrous oxide and you want to know who's
actually making the biggest contribution
to the greenhouse effect so in order to
do this we have to convert all those
gasses to what we're gonna call co2
equivalent the analogy is like money if
I if I had something in dollars so I
have enough some item and that's worth a
certain amount of dollars I have another
item that's worth a certain amount of
pesos I got a third item that's worth
certain the number of euros and my
question is which one is the most
expensive I won't know till I convert
them all to the same currency what we're
doing here is we're going to convert all
the gases to the same currency of co2
and we're going to use a global warming
potential to do this okay I'm gonna work
through a problem so let's say we have a
cement plant and the cement plant is
emitting 1,200 kilograms of co2 per day
okay and then we have a gas plant that
processes natural gas we'll talk more
about this later and it is it is
emitting 150 kilograms of methane per
day okay then we have a fertilizer plant
and let's say it is emitting 25
kilograms of nitrous oxide per day all
right
so the question is if this is the
scenario where we focus here then I
compare these three who is contributing
the most to the greenhouse effect okay
so what we said a few minutes ago is
that we need the greenhouse effect to
survive on the planet but as humans
we're adding more to it here we have
three different outfits that are
emitting greenhouse gases but what we
want to know is who's adding the most ok
who's who's making the biggest
contribution to to the greenhouse effect
through greenhouse gas emissions so in
order to do this we're going to convert
everything to co2
now cement plant it's already n co2 so
I'd have to do anything ok
no work ok that's done so what I do have
to do is take the gas plant and I want
to convert I want to say ok if it if it
is emitting 150 kilograms of ch4 what is
the equivalent amount of co2 that that
would be or converting currency here ok
so I'm going to take 150 this is ch4 and
what I'm going to do is multiply that
number times the global warming
potential so the global warming
potential of methane ch4 is 25 1
molecule of ch4 is worth 25 co2 s all
right so I multiply that by 25 okay so
I'm gonna take $150 25 I get 3000
750 kilograms of co2 equivalent okay so
I so that 150 kilograms of ch4 is the
same amount of global warming potential
as three thousand seven hundred fifty
kilograms of co2 all right let's do the
fertilizer plant so I've got 25
kilograms of n2o nitrous oxide and I
look up the goe P of n 2o it's 298 so
multiply by 298 25 times 298 I get seven
thousand four hundred and fifty
kilograms a co2 equivalent okay
sometimes we get really tired of writing
out the word equivalent so what you'll
see instead is co2 eq and sometimes in
parentheses that means equivalent co2
alright so we've converted currency's
our cement plant is twelve hundred
kilograms of co2 our gas plant is
equivalent to three thousand seven
hundred fifty kilograms of co2 and a
fertilizer plant is equivalent to seven
thousand four hundred and fifty
kilograms of co2 so who's making the
biggest contribution fertilizer plant
okay so even though it was the smallest
overall amount in terms of mass of gases
these nitrous oxide gives such a potent
greenhouse effect overall when you
multiply the whole thing out times the
global warming potential you find out
that it actually makes the biggest
contribution so if you're one of my
students you'll have a couple of these
problems you'll have to work out this
week okay so here's a breakdown of the
major greenhouse gases that are emitted
in the United States and they've been
converted to co2
so it says percentages based on MMT
million mega ton that's just a gigantic
number don't worry too much about that
co2 equivalent okay so what this is
showing is that 82% of all the
greenhouse gas emissions that we produce
in the United States is co2 okay and if
you convert the other ones to co2
equivalent so there's methane and
there's not just oxide and then here's a
whole bunch of it yeah of the other ones
what you see is that even though these
are a stronger greenhouse gas as a
nation we emit co2 by such a greater
volume that this is the greenhouse gas
that we typically focus on we're talking
about global warming issues the co2 is
the number-one gas that we're worried
about that doesn't mean we don't worry
about these others we do because they do
have a greenhouse effect but co2 is by
far the biggest one that we worry about
so here's another way to look at those
same numbers over time so the blue is
how much co2 we've emitted each year
then the red is the methane Green is
nitrous oxide and then purple has served
a whole bunch of other ones all thrown
together as time has gone on you'll see
there's kind of this overall trend from
early 1990 early 1990s to the mid 2000s
where every year as a country we're
emitting more and more greenhouse gases
and again these are and you can't really
even wrap your mouth around these
numbers so this is 7,000 million
megatons so you have to basically add 12
zeros onto the ends of these numbers but
don't worry about that it's just a
meaningless gigantic number to you
notice what happens here 2008 things go
downhill a little bit so the world
economy slowed down we stopped buying
things we stopped building things we
stopped burning so much fuel and we see
that there's a little drop-off here but
as years go by you can see that the
trends are pretty similar right that as
a nation we tend to emit mostly co2 and
then methane and nitrous oxide is our
greenhouse gases
so we're gonna talk about what we do to
generate some of these greenhouse gases
so again you this is part of the figures
that are on this handout that I've got
on learn if you're in my class so
sources of co2 emissions again in this
million Megaton co2 equivalent okay
fossil fuel combustion now before I talk
about that look at some of the ones
below here non energy use of fuels iron
and steel production natural gas systems
cement production and down here on the
x-axis are numbers in this million
Megaton co2 so 25 50 75 but this very
first one is so long it would be off the
page on through next several pages and
it would end over here at five thousand
so what they did is they put a little
dash right here to show that this is not
continuous that the rest of these bars
you know this is 150 that's the scale so
this moves on for you know a dozen pages
later if this was all to scale okay so
that number right there that 5050 that
is a so much larger number than all of
these so what this is saying is that the
number one source of co2 is burning
fossil fuels that's the number one thing
we do more than anything else then we've
got some of these other things you
probably have heard at least heard about
some of these things so when we make
cement that adds co2 to the air when we
make RN steel add co2 to the air all
these things add some co2 to the air but
that very first one that fossil fuel
combustion boy that is by large by far
the number one thing that we do so in
this table we are breaking down the co2
further so we said that this number
right here this 5050 is so five thousand
50 million megatons of co2 were produced
in 2015 in the United States for burning
fossil fuels yeah that's what that
there's that number we can break that
down further all of that five thousand
50 million
megatonnes 1900 was for generating
electricity
17:36 was for transportation 805 was for
residential or I'm sorry industrial 319
was for residential now reason I'm
bringing this up is that most people
don't realize that when we talk about
burning fossil fuels ok we're generating
co2 from burning fossil fuels the number
one thing we burn fossil fuels to do in
this country is not to drive cars the
number one thing is this one generating
electricity so we produced more co2 from
generating electricity by burning fossil
fuels then we do say burning fossil
fuels in our cars cars ships everything
airplanes etc that's transportation
that's number two so number one
generating electricity
number two transportation and then it
breaks down further from there when we
get to methane the number one source of
methane in this country is something
called enteric fermentation
what does enteric fermentation fancy way
of saying cow farts so cows they eat
grass grass goes down they got this
weird for stomach system and so you
heard about cows chewing their cud right
so they they chewed this grass that goes
down and eventually they comes back up
and they chew for a while and it goes
back down there's bacteria down there
and the bacteria produced methane and
methane some come sometimes comes out
the front end sometimes comes up the
back end of the cow but cows produce a
lot of methane as a country we really
like our hamburgers so we have a lot of
cows and cows produce a lot of methane
that's enteric fermentation that's the
number one source of methane in our
country number two is natural gas so
we're going to talk about this in a
future lecture but when we extract
natural gas out of the ground some of it
gets into the atmosphere
number three is landfills so this is
where all your garbage goes they just
throw in a big hole in the ground and
cover it bacteria decay that that the
garbage
then that produces methane manure
management might be a career option if
if college isn't working out for you
coal mining petroleum systems wastewater
treatment that's where all your sewer
goes methane is produced through that so
there's a bunch of them here and here's
a breakdown of nitrous oxide and number
one on the list is agricultural soil
management so this is another one of
those graphs that they have the break
because it's so bigger so much bigger
than all the other ones so number one by
far is agricultural soil manager what
does that mean so plants need nitrogen
but they can't take nitrogen out of the
air they have to take it out of the soil
but there's a limited amount of nitrogen
in the soil so what humans have done is
they figured out how to add nitrogen to
the soil making we make something called
synthetic fertilizer and they look like
these little babies you throw them into
the soil and they break down and they
produce nitrogen that the plants can
absorb well one of the byproducts of
that is some of that produces nitrous
oxide which then goes into the
atmosphere okay so that's your number
one here by far number two stationary
combustion that's something that's
burning but not moving like it could be
an engine that's not moving anywhere it
could be a fire manure management again
mobile combustion okay so now you got an
engine that's on the move wastewater
treatment again so on down the line so
the number one though by far is
agricultural soil management so if we
think about all of the variety of
sources that is the greenhouse gases
were putting into the atmosphere and
sinks these are things that remove
greenhouse gases from the atmosphere it
kind of looks like this so this is on
the y axis it says million megatons of
co2 equivalent right so we're taking all
the different greenhouse gases
converting all of them to co2 equivalent
throwing it all together and looking at
what we got is a country so the blue is
energy okay so most of the greenhouse
gases are from this energy sector
so that's electricity that's
transportation energy is a lot of a lot
of things there then the red is
agriculture then the green is industrial
processes of some kind this little blue
here is waste so that's mostly us
throwing things away and then this
little tiny one
it says L u L u CF which stands for a
land-use line use change and forestry
okay and we'll talk more about this in a
little later lecture okay so as time has
gone on as the economy has grown you can
see overall the amount of greenhouse
gases has gone up and up and up like we
saw an earlier slide then the economy
kind of crashes in 2008 and drops down
again but by and large the the number
one thing that we do as humans to
produce greenhouse gases is generating
energy of some kind right either
electricity or our cars or what have you
also notice this purple which is
negative okay this is what we call a
sync so what that means is these are
processes that take co2 or other
greenhouse gases out of the air and
remove them well what would that be so
imagine a really intensive farming if
you plant a lot of plants in a tiny area
then they're going to pull down co2 out
of the atmosphere and they'll actually
offset some of the co2 that we've been
putting into the atmosphere so that's
what we mean is a sink that's this
purple